Film Courage: When you executive produce a movie are
you putting in your own funds? Stanley Brooks, Producer: Well when
you executive produce a movie for a
network and you're on the hook for
deficit it's all your own funds so if
it's a 2.7 million dollar movie and
you've gotten money from lifetime and
money from an international distributor
let's say Sony and you're shooting in
Winnipeg so you have a 25% tax rebate
all of that doesn't get paid when you
shoot it gets paid in draws along the
way and the biggest draw is usually on
delivery so you spend all of the money
before you deliver it so you've got to
go to a bank unless you're independently
wealthy which I'm not and borrow it so
the tax credits are borrowed against the
network's license fee or funding is
borrowed against the international
distribution fee is borrowed against so
in some ways is all of your money and
then of course if it's a 2.7 million
dollar movie and you end up spending 2.8
million dollar movie that's your money
there's nobody to go back to and say I
need more the International supers not
going to give you more that networks not
gonna give you more and obviously the
tax credit people are not gonna give you
more so so you got to make sure you
spend 2 7 and maybe if you can spend 2 6
5 and not affect the outcome of the
movie putting a little extra money in
your pocket but generally yes it's all
your money or the bank's money
what is gap insurance gap insurance is
four independent features where there is
a gap between how much money you've
raised and how much you need an
insurance company will cover that on the
idea that there's money going to be
coming in once it gets released seen in
the feature business you have up side
television movie business we don't get
to share in the advertising so once I
deliver a movie there's no more profit
for me so I have to make it on the
television movie itself before I deliver
there's no net profits there's no gross
profits there's no no there's no
box-office right so there's no it's not
even pay-per-view so there's nobody
sending me a check after I've delivered
my television movie it's a lifetime or
hallmark or CBS NBC ABC box in the
future business there's box office the
there's pay per view there's streaming
there's all these sales that can get
made that can generate more income so
the gap insurance is looking at all
those revenue streams and saying okay is
this a good bet if it's good Pat will
you pay for an insurance policy and
we'll give you the money and then we'll
recoup it from you but you're gonna get
it from all those other revenue streams
how do you talk to someone into giving
you money normally uh you gotta be a
really good storyteller
I think pitching has got to be your best
skill if you're asking somebody for
money because they're not investing in
the movie they're investing in you
they're counting on you to deliver that
story you just told them they're really
counting on you they're hoping that your
experience and your talent is what's
going to get it across the finish line
and make them money so if I'm pitching a
network they're counting on me to
deliver that movie that I just pitched
them not to hand it off to someone and
they count on my experience and my
background to be what's gonna get them
the movie that they want and if it's an
independent financier and some some rich
person that wants to invest in the movie
and it's even more tenuous because they
don't have advertising that's gonna
cover them they don't know where the
money's gonna come back from so it's
it's more risky so you better be a
really good storyteller
you better be confident passionate I
think passion is the most important
thing you can bring to a pitch you know
my favorite quote about Hollywood is
from William Goldman where he's the
thesis of his book adventures in the
screen trade is nobody knows anything
and the truth is we don't will otherwise
every movie will be a hit and every
series would be 40 share but they're not
and nobody sets out to make a flop so
every time you go in you have the
highest of expectations and yet we don't
know what's gonna happen we don't know
which ones are gonna work and not work
my friends
you know Marta Kauffman and David Crane
who I went to Brandeis with when they
wrote friends they sure as hell had no
idea that's what they were gonna have
and I have friends you know on the other
side of that coin who do things that
everybody says is going to be hit
and I remember when I worked in Coober
Peters we had a movie with Dennis Quaid
who was a big star in Martin Short who
was an even bigger star and it was the
highest testing at that moment it was
produced by Steven Spielberg and goober
Peters so there are these two powers
producers and at that moment in time it
was the highest rated highest testing
comedy in Warner Brothers history and
there was a movie called inner space and
it was a massive flop and nobody
predicted that nobody knows anything so
if you're not passionate about it if you
don't bring to that meeting where you're
asking somebody for money incredible
passion and desire and enthusiasm to try
and get them to overcome those fears but
nobody knows anything then the chances
they're gonna buy it are pretty slim
where I think about the Blair Witch
Project but I mean it especially I did
found footage movie that it just it
didn't seem like it would be something
and paranormal activity but there you go
yeah South Park was a Christmas greeting
card that got sent around and Comedy
Central saw it tell me you really don't
know nobody knows anything nobody put
the put those shows on and when I
thought that's gonna be a hit or that's
gonna be a flop so from the passionate
storytelling point of view is that
something you saw with Peter Guber I
mean did he oh my yeah both Peter and
John were two of the best people at
pitching I ever saw I learned at the
feet of the masses but even even my
mentor Tom Tannenbaum who who taught me
the business before I met Peter and John
was extraordinary at pitching yeah I
watched I learned it at the feet of the
Masters they were they were
extraordinary and you know when there
was three networks and those are the
only places you could go to sell
something you better be good at pitching
because there was no other place to go
once they said no you heard three knows
you were done now you you know you could
be here until the cows come home and
still not have pitched every network
that can buy so you know some luxury now
you can just keep going and going and
going with a good idea
but when I started three places to go
and if they said no you were done can
you pass on some knowledge from what
you've learned from your mentors at the
feet of the Masters issues well Peter
was a very big believer in getting
looking for an opportunity in every
pitch to make a connection to the person
Peter was extraordinary at coming in
scanning the room spotting a photo or a
ward or something and having a personal
connection to it so he could make a
personal connection to the person buying
and he would immediately connect to them
even if he never met them so by the time
he went in to start to pitch there was a
familiarity between the two Oh our kids
went to school together or oh you're a
fan of the New York Giants or oh you
grew up in in Brookline I grew up in
Newton you know these are the things
that he was extraordinary at he also
could read a room and that's the other
thing people don't do well anymore he
was extraordinary of that he could feel
like he he believed and I as do i and I
teach in my class
there's the lean forward and lean back
theory which is if the person you're
selling to leans forward they are
interested they're hooked they start to
lean back you're losing them and so
don't keep pitching when they're
starting to lean back wrap it up or go
jump to something that's gonna get them
to lean forward again but read the room
watch what's going on see what they're
reacting to and if it's a pass remember
what worked in that pitch and make sure
that that's what you lean on the next
pitch that the things that didn't work
you kind of skirt around she's not gonna
tell the whole story you're not gonna
tell every character in the story so you
know it was like a comedian and doing a
set at the Comedy Store don't repeat the
jokes that don't work and he was great
at it but he but you know he had
enormous passion for everything he sold
you believed that this was the only
movie he ever cared about all the other
movies he made he didn't care about that
this one is the one he made you feel
that and I think you have to do that I
try I don't know if I'm certainly not as
good as Peter is but you know
you have to make people feel that this
is the most important movie right that
minute what about when he felt something
wasn't right like you he should pass on
it over was some of the the gut
instincts that he would get when I would
pitch to him so that's the death the
other side of the coin he you had to get
him quick here very limited attention
span so you better he better respond to
it fast so you better get out whatever
it is the hook the concept it's where I
learned the importance of concept
because I think concept is the most
important thing in a pitch concept first
then characters then plot plot being the
least important thing and so I learned
how to get you know the sort of essence
of what I was pitching to him out fast
with a bit of a hook and some like an
action verb something that would get him
excited right off the bat I wouldn't
wait there's no benefit in a slow start
on a pitch there's no reeling them in
quietly so that was Peter and I learned
that from him
you